add olive oil to a flatbread then place  in a hot frying pan and toast until  crisp and golden on both sides  these deliciously versatile breads are  made without yeast and are available in  good supermarkets and local  middle-eastern shops next thinly sliced  fresh fennel and scatter over the  toasted flatbread then toast aromatic  fennel seeds in a hot dry pan and  sprinkle on top  crumpled over wonderfully tangy feta  cheese finish with a drizzle of sweet  and sticky pomegranate molasses  bread transformed before your eyes  flatbread with fennel and feta simple  delicious and ready to eat in minutes  next drain your pasta and combine with a  sardine chili and garlic mixture add  leaves of fresh oregano  finish with freshly grated Parmesan  perfect when you're really busy